esta es la historia de david y goliat
aplicada a nuestra empresa gerardo mi
socio y yo éramos dos david es literal
teníamos éramos unos huecos de 17 años
estábamos en la preparatoria con un
sueño transformar el sistema educativo a
través de tecnología para algunos un
sueño iluso pero para nosotros un
objetivo muy claro
creamos una aplicación sencilla buscando
transformar modelos educativos y nuestro
primer objetivo era que toda nuestra
universidad la utilizar
pero había un pequeño detalle teníamos
que lograr que el rector nos escuchar
que le podemos presentar y que le
podríamos vender nuestra idea era david
quería no hablar con goleadas entonces
gerardo y yo fuimos a buscar la cita
y vamos con el rector y vamos a dar a su
oficina la asistente nos decía vengan
mañana tengan la siguiente semana y
bueno pasaron un par de semanas en que
intentamos conseguir esa cita
hasta que un día investigamos sobre la
vida del rector y el rector iba a misa
todas las mañanas entonces gerardo y yo
llevábamos nuestra tablet
llevábamos nuestros folletos y nuestras
ideas y fuimos a la iglesia cercana de
la universidad pensamos que el rector yo
así que es bueno o sorpresa después de
dos veces afuera el inglés e intentando
presentar el rector pues bueno no estaba
nos volvimos a investigar y hasta
encontramos donde vivía el rector
entonces de ahí nos fuimos a la iglesia
a la que el rector iba
nos pusimos afuera y estábamos listos
para atacarlo traíamos nuestra tablet
nuestros folletos le presentamos un poco
lo que queríamos hacer y nos dijo chavos
eso está muy interesante para adelante
implementarlo en los campos de la ciudad
de mexico
eso estuvo increíble recuerdo gerardo y
yo ese verano donde pasamos en una
biblioteca una biblioteca del tec
que habría 24 horas en aquel tiempo me
acuerdo que tenía unas mesas gigantescas
y bueno gerardo se llevaba su almohada y
dormía en las mesas justo para poder
implementar el software que fue lanzado
después de ese verano
nos dimos cuenta que cuando tenías un
porque contenía es muy claro lo que
querías um porque en la vida podías
hacer hasta lo que pareciera imposible
para poder alcanzar esta historia inicia
en la prepa y nyse en la prepa
con dos nerds literalmente dos nerds y
usaba lentes tenía frenos y también
tenía espinillas entonces
como buenos nerds pues queríamos
transformar el mundo teníamos este
porque qué bien les digo y
y bueno en ese tiempo estábamos en
muchos grupos de ayudar a niños a leer
de ayora niños en el tema del
aprendizaje nos metíamos a temas de
inglés pero aquí hay algo interesante
veíamos que los niños no se enganchaban
con el aprendizaje veíamos que los niños
o si vamos a dar la clase decían
profesor quiero jugar fútbol y bueno yo
como buen nerd
no sabía jugar fútbol entonces tiene que
hacer algo al respecto y de ahí dijimos
bueno qué podemos hacer cómo lo podemos
manejar tanto a gerardo como a mí nos
encantaba programar e hicimos tenemos
que crear algo enganche de los alumnos
hacia el aprendizaje así como nosotros
gusta estudiar tenemos que ayudar a que
más les gusta estudiar
y bueno nos pusimos a investigar
llegamos con un estudio de un profesor
de física de harvard que decía que sus
clientes eran muy buenos pero se daba
cuenta que no estaban entendiendo muy
bien las cosas y él hizo un estudio bien
interesante en donde muestra la
actividad cerebral por esto lo han visto
en algunas otras conferencias pues la
actividad cerebral del alumno en
diferentes momentos del día no sé si se
alcance a ver pero bueno en esta
actividad cerebral llama mucho la
atención pues el alumno tiene buena
actividad cerebral haciendo tareas tiene
una actividad cerebral está viendo la
televisión algo bien interesante había
más actividad cerebral cuando el alumno
dormía que cuando iba a clases entonces
todo hizo sentido por eso me quedaba
dormido en clase de física
de ahí empezamos a decir que podemos
hacer empezamos a desarrollar nuestra
primera aplicación y nos pusimos a
cuestionarnos si realmente queremos
transformar la educación no sólo es en
una universidad nos empezamos a
cuestionar cómo realmente podemos ayudar
a la gente a las personas a ser exitosas
a través del aprendizaje pero cómo
podemos llegar a un billón de personas
ese fue nuestro cuestionamiento
e imagínense si los niños no se
enganchaban si yo me quedaba dormido
siendo nerd el reto de enganchar a un
billón de personas
algo que vimos es que la tecnología
educativa existente se enfocaba a
transmitir conocimiento y pues bueno
transmitir conocimiento en algo ya
obsoleto el conocimiento se encontraba
en cualquier parte normalmente veíamos
plataformas espacios donde podías tomar
cursos pero seguía repitiendo el mismo
modelo tradicional escuchar un profesor
presentar un examen y ser certificado y
no necesariamente personalizada no
necesariamente entendía cada persona no
entendía cuál era el propósito de cada
persona y cómo ayudarle para poder
alcanzar ese propósito nos dimos cuenta
que la tecnología estaba lista para
mucho más
había inteligencia artificial había
muchas herramientas que podíamos
utilizar para poder entender a cada una
de las personas
aquí viene otra historia cuando dijimos
que queríamos llegar a un millón de
personas es la parte más importante en
este mundo es poder internacionalizarse
nuestro producto lo que habíamos
desarrollado no solamente lo podemos
vender en méxico sino también lo
teníamos que vender en eeuu
y dijimos bueno pues vamos a eeuu a
vender nuestro producto
recuerdo que muchos nos dijeron estás
loco nunca has vendido nada en eeuu no
te conocen son un par de estudiantes ni
que fueras bill gates entonces aun así
gerardo y yo tomamos el avión recuerdo
que hasta pedimos un traje prestado
fuimos eeuu como buenos empresarios a
presentar nuestro producto otra vez la
historia de david y goliat queriendo
venderle a una de las empresas más
grandes a nivel global una semana
después de ese viaje habíamos logrado
vender una empresa fortune 100 y nuestra
compañía ha empezado a crecer
algo que nos quedó muy claro nos
empezamos a cuestionar y decir como lo
estamos logrando lo que pasa es cuando
tienes un propósito claro en la vida
ese propósito claro pero sobre todo con
sentido que realmente sirva que
realmente ayude a alguien de ese
propósito que genera una especie de
ceguera es una ceguera buena porque una
ceguera buena porque no hace que no veas
los obstáculos
hace que sólo veas el objetivo y luches
para poder conseguir ese objetivo
y bueno esta historia de david y goliat
se repite constantemente todavía hace un
par de semanas es un par de meses que
inició todo esto
decidimos participar en la licitación de
tecnología educativa más grande de
américa latina'
una fácil claramente y competíamos
contra los grandes contra empresas que
valían billones de dólares
y empresas que cotizaban en bolsa
entonces
otra vez
algunos socios en diferentes países
estábamos entrando a este país nos
decían oye has iniciando porque quieres
irte por la más grande oye
no lo vas a poder hacer está complicado
también nos decían recuerdo que alguien
en méxico me llevó a decir como que eres
medio terco o testarudo no sé qué
y además todos los días una colaboradora
que trabaja conmigo no recordaba no se
vayan a decepcionar si pierdas
hace un par de semanas después de una
guerra literalmente gripa dolor de
estómago mucho estrés que vivió todo mi
equipo ganamos esta licitación y otra
vez se repetía esta historia david y
goliat
yo me cuestionaba a mí mismo qué es lo
que pasa porque se repite la historia de
vida goleado como es que lo estamos
haciendo en un gran cuestionamiento
en hacía
aquí está david y goliat
y dijimos
básicamente lo que lo explica es que
cuando combinas
acción con propósito y rutas claras
nosotros estamos apasionados por lograr
algo algo que tenga sentido en la vida
estás dispuesto a hacer lo que sea
necesario no importa que sea mientras lo
tengas eso se vuelve el motor de tu vida
y literalmente puede ser david que le
gana golea
de aquí viene un poco el descuento cuál
es mi propósito
nos damos cuenta al raíz de tener un
propósito de vida que va dando sentido
todo lo que tú hagas en la vida se
vuelve una experiencia de aprendizaje
todo lo que hagas te vas dando cuenta
que cada parte de tu vida te va llevando
a poder cumplir tu propósito ya sea esa
experiencia aprendizaje sea buena sea
mala o sea fea
y algo también importante yo soy un
hombre muy creyente tengo mucha fe en
dios y dios te va poniendo las cosas
bueno las oportunidades se van poniendo
los lugares las personas que hacen que
puedas cumplir ese propósito ya está en
ti poder luchar por él
cuál es mi propósito el propósito y aquí
lo pongo impulsar el poder del
aprendizaje
cuando digo impulsar el porn del
aprendizaje es ayudar a otras personas a
encontrar su propósito
para que puedan ser exitosos a través
del aprendizaje pero la prensa/g es todo
como les digo es estas rutas un conjunto
de experiencias que pueden seguir si yo
hubiera sabido que había posibles
experiencias de aprendizaje hace nueve
años que iniciamos nuestra compañía o la
primera compañía que hicimos lo bueno
probablemente hubiera acelerado mi
propósito y eso lo que queremos ayudar a
más personas a poder alcanzarlo y
primero sobre todo por encontrar cuál es
su propósito
el tema es el modelo educativo el modelo
extractivo tradicional no se enfoca a
ayudar a la gente a cumplir este
propósito el modelo educativo lo que
hace es generar una ruta que es igual
para todos donde tiene es un conjunto de
materias donde no necesariamente estas
materias se desarrollan las habilidades
o competencias para tu propósito les voy
a poner un ejemplo uno desarrolla más
liderazgo cuando es líder de su equipo
de basketball en la escuela que cuando
tomas la clase de liderazgo uno y además
esto te lleva a que tú tengas un título
en donde no seriamente el título habla
de ti necesariamente te lleva hacia un
propósito de vida
y por otro lado yo por ejemplo soy
ingeniero en sistemas gerardo mi socio
señor en sistemas tienen un lugar dice
que gerardo es mejor programador a la
mejor yo soy mejor consultor y eso es un
poco lo que hoy se está buscando
cuál es el modelo que proponemos es un
modelo que es una película una película
en donde uno vive un conjunto de
experiencias de aprendizaje no importa
de qué tipo puede ser
como les decía un equipo de basquetbol
pues un tema cultural pues una práctica
profesional puede ser hasta una charla
con una persona o pues en un evento como
este y cada una de estas experiencias
nos va llevando a desarrollar un
conjunto de habilidades un conjunto de
competencias que nos pueden ayudar a
poder cumplir nuestro propósito ya sea
un empleo ya sea ser emprendedor ya sea
convertirse en un artista
aquí lo importante es que el modelo se
basa en ti y cuando digo en ti es
entender a cada persona hacia dónde
quiere llegar basado en sus decisiones
por otro lado y generando un perfil de
competencias de cada persona y por otro
lado ponemos un catálogo un conjunto de
posibles experiencias de aprendizaje que
no importa si son presenciales si son en
línea si es un deporte o existe una
actividad cultural y utilizan la
inteligencia artificial comparamos ese
perfil contra lo que tú quieres
encontramos la brecha y te recomendamos
una ruta de experiencias de aprendizaje
para poder cumplir y ayudamos también a
las instituciones a incrementar sus
índices de empleabilidad ya los jóvenes
sobre todo a poder encontrar su
propósito
y bueno todo propósito conlleva un
conjunto de esfuerzos todo propósito
conlleva un conjunto de experiencias de
aprendizaje personas esto también es
importante que encuentres a aquellas
personas que te van a ayudar a poder
cumplir con ese propósito y no son
personas que tengan muchas habilidades
que tengan muchos conocimientos o que
tengan muchas competencias realmente son
personas que comparten el propósito
contigo que tengan los valores y que
realmente quieran transformar e impactar
y servir y junto con ellas puedes
alcanzar lo que quieras en mi caso mi
esposa que está aquí todos los días me
apoya y me dice guillermo echarle para
adelante si fuera fácil cualquiera mis
padres desde que soy niño mi hermano que
también están aquí todos los días me
decían desde niño lucha por lo que
quieres y luego les cuento sobre mi
socio que ha estado a través de toda
esta conferencia él y yo nunca nos hemos
peleado recuerdo con iniciamos la
empresa alguien nos dijo se van a pelear
y dije porque nunca nos hemos peleado y
porque no nos hemos peleado porque
compartimos un propósito no importa si
nos equivoquemos no importa si nos
caigamos no importa lo que hagamos los
dos estamos luchando por lo mismo por
los mismos valores y esa es la parte más
importante que deben de tener muy claro
el propósito no sé no se trata sólo de
pensarlo el propósito se trata de
hacerlo un amigo colombiano hace unas
semanas me decían
el que piensa pierde él se queda
pensando pierde y el que se queda
haciendo gana
entonces los invito a vivir este viaje
los invito a vivir un viaje con
propósito un viaje que tenga sentido un
viaje en que cada experiencia se vuelve
una experiencia de aprendizaje a darle
con todo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]